it's great to be joined today by Erika
Walker who's a post doctoral researcher
at Boston University's School of Public
Health also director of the community
noise lab Erika thanks so much for
talking to me today thank you so let's
start I mean for people who don't know
the effect of noise in their environment
and how this can impact mental health
and and physical health big picture it
for us I mean what are the
considerations when we think about what
what types and level of noise can be bad
for humans to be exposed to on a regular
basis well if you look at traditional
epidemiological literature you'll see
that when we describe sound in our
communities we typically describe it by
its loudness and we see that loudness as
low as 40 a weighted decibels can you
can see changes in your mood annoyance
irritation and then as we move up you
know 40 50 65 decibels we began to see
more serious to disease manifestation
such as cardiovascular disorders
myocardial infarction high blood
pressure you know up to 65 decibels yeah
I mean just when I hear that truck
backing up near your office I
immediately start to sense that I feel
like I'm sweating a tiny bit and I start
to not know it we it's funny because we
had an office situation for the last
three years up until a few weeks ago
where we it was basically a building
that was constantly under construction
and because we work in sound we happen
to have a decibel meter and it's very
clear that once the noise gets to a
certain level concentration becomes
difficult there is a physical impact and
this is something that I'm guessing
disproportionately impacts people who
are not wealthy and a lot of the the
communities impacted disproportionately
are the ones we would expect is that
right that's very right so you know in
some of the research I released a noise
report in 2016 and you can definitely
see that in areas that were located in
your major transportation networks so
near airports
two bus lines train stations those were
typically the poorer communities but
they also have the higher noise levels
so of course sometimes when driving on
highways you will see these sort of wood
they looked like there would sort of
barriers that are created and I believe
that the idea of those is to reduce
highway noise for the communities that
that are nearby can you talk about that
and other of the very common methods
that are used and sort of how effective
they are at mitigating noise that's
assuming that cities take it seriously
right you know so I've seen sound walls
but I think most of the mitigation
strategies are have typically been on a
case-by-case basis some persons with
lots of money hires an acoustics firm
and they soundproof their homes but
other than that its sound walls and then
if you live near an airport when
sometimes if you live near a major
highway you can apply for you know
window treatments but that's very strict
criteria very crazy criteria so even if
you live in those neighborhoods you're
not guaranteed the protections because
you have to be eligible for the
soundproofing criteria but for me and
what I've seen it seems to be something
mitigation strategies seem to be
something that's available to people who
can afford them and those things that
are available to those people who can
afford them a lot of people don't
qualify for them well their people may
not know and it's not it would be
understandable why that there was
something called the noise Control Act
of 1972 and that was shut down so can
you can you talk a little bit about what
that did and and the sort of problem
with getting rid of it so I think it's
sort of brought to our consciousness
that there that noise was at that time a
serious health issue but that is
something that we would predict in the
future living people seriously I work in
a corner
no problem Wow this is right next to the
emergency room so I think that it it put
us into this this mindset this noise
something that we need to talk about and
it's something that's going to get worse
in the future if we don't do something
about it but I think that what did the
the dismantling of this office of noise
abatement has kind of left the
regulation of noise to these very bucket
kind of entities primarily your city or
your town so it's just sort of put these
things in silos so there's no longer
that framework to kind of make sure that
everyone's speaking the same common
language how do we kind of like define
or categorize different types of noise
because I can certainly imagine two or
three or five different types of noise
that are sort of the same decibel level
if you were to measure it but I think we
can all sort of understand how the
impact on on mental health and our
feeling would be very different so like
a white noise machine for example that
is designed to maybe help you sleep
better would be very different than
other types of noise that might be
equally loud so how can we start
thinking of how we might categorize
noise great question so typically what
we've always the way we've always talked
about noise was how loud it was right
we've talked about oh this is loud this
is loud this is not loud so we've only
very superficially defined how we talk
about noise and the way we regulate it
is we regulate it using this a weighted
decibel that assumes that the noise
that's important for us to regulate is
the noise that we process through at an
auditory system but research suggests
that number one we don't process noise
only through our auditory system and in
areas where there are high components of
low frequency and high frequency noise
so frequency is another aspect of new is
that we really don't take into
consideration they do more so an
Occupational setting but in our you know
environmental community noise
regulations we just typically focus on
the sounds that we can hear so you know
if we live in a neighborhood where there
are
high levels of lower frequency and
higher frequency noise this a weight
adjustable which says that because of we
there's only certain types of noise
along certain frequencies that we
process through the auditory system
those other frequencies those really low
frequencies and those higher frequencies
don't really matter so when we were
talking earlier about communities poor
communities being louder they're also
more inundated with lower frequency and
higher frequency sounds what are some
examples of that sounds would be more of
your rumbling so like in my case the
thing that got me interested in noise
research was my neighbors upstairs who
would stuff all day thunder bus engine
things that have a war to it whereas
higher frequencies or things like
crickets ambulance siren things with the
kind of eerie kind of pitch to it so we
don't even consider that really when
we're talking about regulate regulating
our community soundscapes so we talked
about loudness we sort of not really
care about the frequencies so in these
communities poor communities what I saw
in my research was that not only of
these communities poor but there also
have more sources of lower and higher
frequency sounds what kind of causative
question is using this any way to
decibel the appropriate nature to
regulate the soundscape and then we
talked about sound but then we talked
about noise being the unwanted aspect of
sound and we sort of really don't
consider that we assume that the
unwanted this is the loudness of it but
it could be the character or the
frequency it could be the duration of it
and it could be from an individual
sensitivity or perception which things
we really don't consider things we
really don't regulate around so their
sound that has its own components
there's noise which has like community
components and individual components but
things that we really don't talk about
one of the if you were to say what are
some of the sort of most relaxing or
pleasing sounds I can imagine being a
completely untrained person in this
field I would
or to think about white noise machines
that are designed specifically for you
know a therapy session to make it hard
to hear what's going on or for sleeping
like I have when in my in my bedroom
ocean and water type noises and this can
include also like rain for example what
are first of all can you give us some
examples of the noises that are that are
known to be relaxing but then also like
how can we characterize them what are
their characteristics that we might
identify so I think that you know you
talk about the white noise machine I'm
gonna answer your question but you talk
about the white noise machine so I all I
think that sounds that we have control
over or more likely to be more pleasant
than anything so I think noise is sort
of like a proxy for control over our
environmental soundscape yeah so you
know I have a white noise machine around
tune when people come to visit me
they're like what is that that's like so
horrible sounding and they want me to
turn it off but like for me it's a way
that I can control my soundscape in my
apartment so to me it's it's not noise
it's sound but I think things that
people traditionally have found to be
pleasing would be like you said you know
natural sounding sounds that people like
silence to some people I found there's
like two camps people who just like no
sound at all
and then people were creeped out by
there and the people like music
classical music soothing things those
kinds of things
so let's talk about music a little bit
we we learned some years ago that one of
the so-called enhanced interrogation
techniques that was used in the Middle
East included not not just loud music
but specifically it seemed to be heavy
metal music that was being used so from
a obviously we can all have opinions
about heavy metal music and those might
differ but can you talk from a sort of
scientific perspective what is it that
makes heavy metal music of the style
that was used in these enhanced
interrogation techniques which some of
us call torture what makes it materially
different than other types of music I
think the frequency composition of it
you know this is just from this is my
opinion I don't know what types of
sounds they like what types of
heavy-metal music that uses these
interrogation techniques but you know
it's it's loud probably and it has like
this kind of high frequency pitch that's
like an annoying buzz in your ear I
don't know I grew up within the country
and I don't you know in the summertime
you would get mosquitoes that would fly
in your ear and when they would get
trapped it make this like high-pitched
sound and to me that's just completely
annoying so I'm assuming it's the pitch
probably higher pitches and then the
lower pitches as well the lower
frequencies that kind of constant
something in your chest over a period of
time and in my case my situation my
neighbors above me it drove me insane it
literally drove me insane last thing I
want to touch on is we have people who
listen to our show all over the country
but they are heavily concentrated in
places where lots of people live like
cities so I get emails from people about
upstairs noise noise outside all sorts
of stuff assuming you don't have a
budget to have professional sound
insulation and rooms within rooms built
and all of the stuff that would be done
professionally what what are like the
most effective sound mitigation
techniques that the average person in an
apartment can do white like masking it
so getting some sort of sound that
you're comfortable with that offsets it
so white noise machines I have a
soundtrack that sounds like you're
inside of an airplane so it has like a
rumbling because it keeps me from
hearing the footsteps above me in the
Train outside earplugs work as long as
you keep your ears healthy earplugs
noise cancellation headphones I find
that those things work and you get to
stress just leave your place and go out
for a walk yes that seems like like good
advice so we've been speaking with Erika
Walker who's a post doctoral researcher
at Boston University's School of Public
Health also director of the community
noise lab Erika thank you so much for
talking to us today thank you for having
me have a good one